hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
in this video we're going to learn all
about angular pipes
so now imagine if you could change the
way certain information
looked on the screen this could be with
respect to styling size
or even format you could do this with
the help of pipes
now angular pipes allow its users to
change the format
in which data is being displayed on the
screen we learn about this topic in
detail
so but before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
all right so here's what's in store for
you so we'll see what exactly angular
pipes are
then we'll understand how to use
built-in pipes in angular
then we'll create some custom pipes and
finally we'll understand what pure and
impure pipes are so let's begin
what are angular pipes now as mentioned
earlier
pipes transform data you can think of
this as makeup rooms
where you can beautify the data into a
more desirable format
they also do not alter the data but
change how they appear
so pipes are simple functions that
accept an input value
process and return a transformed value
angular supports
several built-in pipes we'll learn about
them in the coming section
however you can also create custom pipes
some key features of pipes
include the following that is pipes are
defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and lastly
pipes can be provided with arguments by
using the colon sign
so moving on let's see how built-in
pipes and angular work
now angular provides several built-in
pipes to beautify the data being shown
on the user interface
now you can see we have the date pipe
which formats a date value
we have the upper case pipe the
transforms text to uppercase
the lowercase pipe that transforms text
to lowercase
we have the currency pipe we have the
decimal pipe that
transforms the number into a string with
a decimal point
and then we have the percent pipe that
transforms a number to a percentage
now let's see how these built-in pipes
are used in angular so for that let's
head to
our editor that is vs code so here i've
created a folder for pipes
and then created a component called
pipes again
and inside the pipes.component.ts file
i'm creating two properties
for date and name all right so here
let's just create them saying
date today string
you just type string then we have a name
again of type
string all right
and within
this i'm going to say this dot
date today equals new
date dot 2
d string all right
and then i'm going to say this dot name
equals simply long
so here the date today property will
hold today's date
all right and according to our
requirements we can change
the way it is displayed on the ui so for
that let's go to the
component.html file
[Music]
and here let me just display
h1 date which is basically today's date
and i'm going to be interpolating the
property here
date today and i'm just going to display
the date in its normal format
next thing i'm going to do date
pipe using the date pipe i can say
date today
date in uppercase
all right
and then another way i can display it is
i can say date
pipe date today
date
in short you'll see this in the output
and then i can say lowercase
and then finally for name i can just say
name i'm just going to display them in
uppercase
and i'm going to slice it so let's say
name
uppercase
all right and then i'm going to say name
and i'm going to slice it so
six all right so now let's save this and
have a look at our browser
now here you can see that date has been
displayed in the normal format first
and then in the upper case and you can
see that
it does not display the day of the week
and finally when you use the short pipe
it makes sure that it's displayed in
this format
and finally name is displayed in
uppercase and when i slice it
it is displayed from the sixth character
all right so that is how you make use of
built-in pipes so moving on
next up let's have a look at creating
custom pipes
now angular pipes are typescript classes
with the at
pipe decorator so the decorator has a
name property in its metadata
that specifies the pipe and how it is
used
alright so the general steps that you
need to take
to create custom pipes include first you
have to create a typescript class
with an export keyword then you can
decorate it with the add pipe decorator
and pass the name property to it
then you have to implement the pipe
transform interface in the class
next up they have to return the
transform data with the pipe
and lastly we have to add this pipe
class to the declarations area of the
module
where you want to use it so
alternatively you can use a simple
command that is
ng pipe and name of the pipe once you
run the command
two files are created one is the spec.ts
file and one is the dot ts file
all right so now let's have a look at
the editor and see how to create these
custom pipes
so here i am creating a pipe so let's
see ng
g pipe and the name i'm giving is custom
pipe
yeah all right so you can see two uh
files have been created we have the
spector ts and the dot ts file
so now here in our custom pipe
dot ts file i'm just going to
create my own custom pipe you can see
that the pipe transform interface has
been
added here and then the transform uh
method is used to transform the data
right so what i'm going to be doing is
i'll write the code to reverse
a string okay so uh for that i'll write
down the code here
so within my pipe transform interface
i'm going to first create
a value which is going to be the n value
which is basically the transformed value
and it is initialized to string
all right and then we have
the transform method i'm just going to
change unknown to
any
now what i'm going to be doing is this
dot n value
equals value dot
i'm going to make use of the split
method and then i'm going to make use of
the reverse
method and finally i'm going to join it
all right and then i'm just going to
return
this dot n value
and back in my component.html file i'll
just say
h one again
i'll say the reverse of
simply learn is
let's say simply learn
and then pass the custom pipe
all right so basically it has to display
the reverse of the string simply learn
so let's save this and have a look at
the browser all right here we go
so the reverse of the string is being
displayed on the screen
so this is how you can make use of
custom pipes you can create pipes
according to your requirements
uh remember that it does not change the
data at all it only displays
it in a different format altogether all
right so now moving on
let's have a look at pure and impure
pipes now pipes in angular are
classified into
pure and impure vibes all right
now pure pipes use pure functions as a
result of this
the pipe doesn't use any internal state
and the output of the pipe
remains the same as long as the
parameters remain the same
okay so angular calls the pipe only when
it detects a
change in the parameters that are being
passed
and a single instance of the pure pipe
is used throughout all the components
talking about impure pipes an impure
pipe is called for
every change detection cycle in the
input fields
multiple pipe instances are created for
these pipes now inputs passed to these
pipes can be mutable
and by default all pipes are pure pipes
however you can specify impure pipes
using the pure property
all right so let me just show that to
you back
in our pipe.ts file here you can always
specify
if it is pure or impure so just say pure
you can set it to true or false so when
you say
true it means it's a pure pipe and if
it's false then it's an impure pipe
by default all the pipes that you create
are pure pipes
so with that we come to the end of this
session if you have
any doubts or queries regarding this
topic let us know in the comment section
below
so i hope you enjoyed this tutorial and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here